so I recently posted a picture of Jeff
Bezos on my Instagram account
highlighting the fact that Amazon has
increased value in the last hundred and
sixty five days by four hundred billion
dollars and the floodgates opened up
with comments and everybody started
saying this man Jeff Bezos who's worth
150 160 billion dollars doesn't pay his
five hundred and sixty three thousand
employees well they're on welfare
similar to what happened with Walmart
but the comments that I keep hearing
over and over again that is an absolute
cop-out from people is the following you
need money to make money it takes money
to make money all of these people that
like to hide behind the idea of that
rich people started off with money
here's a fact for you only fifteen
percent of millionaires in America
inherited their millions of dollars
eighty five percent ourselves made
matter of fact having money is one of
seven ways of having equity today I'm
going to share with you the other six so
look when we hear the word equity we
think about real estate I have equity in
a home equity in the property of equity
in stocks of equity in bonds have equity
in cash that's equity right we only
think about equity as money if the only
source of equity you have is money you
are one-dimensional let me put it to you
this way if you the only thing you have
is money because somebody died and your
family left you 17 million dollars and
that's the only thing you have and Mario
has the other six elements of equity
long term in the marketplace there is no
way in the world you have the same
amount of value as Mario as in a
marketplace so having said that your
goal watching this is as I go through
the other six is to ask yourself which
one of these do I have because if you
want to make yourself irreplaceable
if you want to make yourself the highest
value in a marketplace your goal is to
be able to have as many of these seven
as possible not just one of the seven
which is money but also the other six so
having said that let me get into the
other six elements of equity number two
so I want you to think about a son a
daughter just inherited seventeen
million dollars but this kid has been
spoiled 22 years old never had a job
before lazy as hell dad died mom died
they get the
millions right they have no clue how to
work you know how quickly that money is
gonna disappear out of their hands let
me give you another example of this how
many times have you seen somebody win
the lotto fifty eight million dollar
winner two hundred twenty million dollar
winner three years later money
disappears because they don't have the
second part which is sweat equity here's
what happens whether you have sweat
equity when you have sweat equity you're
not afraid of working 16-hour days for
six months straight you have a certain
mindset a certain thickness your skin is
thick I can't give a 16 year old kid a
million dollars say go to school to get
sweat equity you're not gonna get it I
can't give a 28 year old after they got
a degree let's just say they're very
small but they've never had a job saying
I'm gonna put a half a million dollars
into you to go to this program to learn
more real hard works all about you
either have sweat equity or you don't